c'est un conseil municipal incomplet qui
s'est réuni mercredi soir à coignières
après la démission du maire et de trois
autres conseillers seuls 25 des 27
sièges étaient pourvus face à cette
situation le préfet a décidé de
convoquer une élection partielle
intégral la commune de coignières va se
représenter devant les électeurs ce que
je trouve très démocratique sur quoi n'y
a rien de voir l'équipe qu'elle veut
avoir pour gouverner cette ville
dominique catelin qui sera selon toute
vraisemblance tête de liste lors du
scrutin la date du 25 novembre est
avancé en attendant le conseil municipal
se chargera comme le veut la loi de
gérer les affaires courantes
lors de la campagne la voie du deuxième
adjoint du maire démissionnaire avec qui
il était rentré en conflit
elle devrait se faire entendre je vais
essayer de réunir surtout l'équivalent
d'une trentaine de personnes et les
faire intervenir et agir vraiment pour
qu'elle soit motivée pour shu qu'elles
choisissent elles mêmes les têtes de
liste je suis pas pour le culte de la
personnalité en ce qui me concerne je
n'ai jamais été donc voilà par contre si
c'est choisi effectivement en toute
conscience et en toute liberté par un
groupe
ma foi à mes yeux ça une valeur morale
moral plus importante
et puis candidat déjà déclaré didier
fischer l'opposant socialiste qui en
2014 avait totalisé 43 % des suffrages
la meilleure des solutions à l'heure
actuelle compte tenu des divisions de la
majorité
compte tenu du fait que de toutes façons
on n'était plus en mesure de gérer
correctement cette ville bientôt on
allait avoir le
le budget complémentaire à voter ce
budget complémentaire n'aurait pas pu
être votée à partir de ce moment là nous
aurions été dans une situation de
blocage et c'est préjudiciable aux
poignets rien et la ville d'une manière
générale reste à savoir si une fois élu
le nouveau conseil pourra mettre les
rancoeurs deux côtés d'autant que les
dossiers importants ne manquent pas et
notamment celui d'une participation à la
création d'une piscine intercommunale
avec maurepas elancourt